my name is maurice patterson i'm the
owner and operator of mmp environmental
solutions we are a commercial grease
drive cleaning service and waste
management company and today we will be
cleaning a commercial grease trap in a
mediterranean restaurant
the function of a grease trap is to
prevent any solids fats oil greases from
dishwasher or dishwashing sinks from
entering your piping system
so the cleaning process typically starts
with me inspecting it making sure it's
functional
typically you want to clean your grease
strap of every three months
i would say that it hasn't been serviced
most likely close to a year
then we unplug the grease trap and we
start to remove all the components
from that step we will compare them to
the clean with the brush washer
so right here we're doing our pump out
we have the wand connected to the
high-powered vacuum pump we'll use the
wand to pump out the entire grease strap
so as you can see there's a lot of
greasing on top of the grease trap and
you can get a glimpse of solids that
have floated to the top as well
for mediterranean restaurants you're
going to get a lot of oils cheeses
you're also going to get a lot of rice
the rice is usually the main contents
that sink to the bottom of the grease
trap that you're going to want to pump
out regularly i would describe it as
yellow grease so yellow grease is
typically grease that's used to make
fries things like that
there's actually two different types of
grease known in the industry you have
brown grease that's typical grease
that's scraped off from pots and pans
that travel down into your dishwasher
and your sink down to your grease trap
and then you also have yellow grease you
can actually sell it certain places they
may recycle that grease and turn it into
biofuel things like that
it's considered liquid gold some
companies will actually pay them for it
so they're incentivized to make sure
that it's not going down the drain
here what i'm using is a putty knife i'm
scraping this old food waste that has
collected on there
organic waste just turns black over time
it's oxidized and turns black
it's a health risk mainly because any
type of overflows from your grease strap
may come in contact with food
we use a pressure washer just to make
sure we're getting all the residual
solids cleaned out
i'm using steel wool just to do a final
scrub down make sure i'm getting into
all the nooks and crannies all the tight
spaces
i do this right before we do a final
spray down with the brush washer
so we dispose of the grease at a water
pollution control facility that will
accept the fat oil in greece and there's
not many places that do accept it so
it's limited but you know we dispose of
an environmentally responsible way
when grease goes on the drain with the
dishwater it's typically hot so grease
or oils when they're hot they're
liquefied when they cool down they
solidify in the drain that may cause
plugging which will in turn cause
backups overflows if it negatively
impacts your sewer system then they can
incur fines they will have to buy a new
grease trap or pay plumbing fees to
rectify the problems the smells you
can't miss it it's one of the most foul
smells ever if you see me wearing a mask
that means it's it's ungodly it's it's
the most foul thing ever